Saludos Ángela pues estoy como puedes
ver aquí en la Explanada de los
inválidos a mi espalda el gran Palacio
El pequeño Palacio y el puente Alexandre
tercero una zona por supuesto bellísima
emblemática de París estamos aquí porque
justamente aquí en la Explanada de los
inválidos va a comenzar en poco menos de
una hora esta manifestación esta marcha
que terminará en la plaza de Italia para
responder a tu pregunta Ángela por lo
que hemos podido apreciar aquí los
ánimos están un poco menos digamos
combativos hay menos menos entusiamos
entusiasmo al menos preliminarmente es
lo que puedo observar esto pudiera estar
relacionado con el hecho de que estamos
en la octava edición de este movimiento
octava jornada de manifestaciones
nacionales venir a protestar cuesta
dinero Usted tiene la autorización por
supuesto es un derecho constitucional
venir a protestar pero si no trabaja no
gana y es duro para muchas familias
hacer el sacrificio de venir a protestar
también está por supuesto Ese temor de
que los convocatorios de que los
sindicatos comiencen a perder un poco de
poder de convocatoria dicho esto se
espera para hoy una afluencia de entre
650.000 y 850.000 personas en todo el
territorio nacional cientos de ciudades
que han respondido de forma positiva a
la convocatoria de la organización
intersindical aquí en París por ejemplo
se espera entre 85.000
y 80.000 personas tomando las calles
importantes señalar lo hemos dicho en
otras ocasiones esa posibilidad de que
las manifestaciones tomen un Matiz
violento en concordancia con esto En
este sentido la policía ha anunciado el
despliegue de efectivos castrenses
adicionales debido a la posible
infiltración de miembros de ideologías
radical o de comportamiento poco Cívico
en estas manifestaciones hasta el
momento pacíficas eso por el lado de la
calle Luis Miguel Quiero preguntarle
ahora cómo avanza el trámite legislativo
usted lo mencionaba al inicio en este
mismo momento desde las nueve de la
mañana se encuentra reunida esa comisión
mixta paritaria siete senadores siete
miembros de la asamblea nacional que
deciden que dan los últimos toques a lo
que será realmente la reforma de
pensiones que va a entrar en vigor
posiblemente o a todas luces Por lo que
hemos podido ver en el en lo que
respecta al contexto Cómo se han
desarrollado los acontecimientos dentro
de poco antes del 26 de Marzo en teoría
un dato diez de estos catorce miembros
de la comisión mixtaparitaria están
completamente a favor de las reforma es
decir que no debe haber sorpresas se
conformará el texto final Como va a
implementarse y luego será votado
primero en el senado y luego en la
asamblea nacional la jornada de mañana
si no hay incidentes en este sentido así
que la protesta de hoy también es una
forma de presionar a lo que está
sucediendo en la asamblea nacional